[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone happy
holidays this is my Christmas dance I
think I'm getting into the spirit with
my favorite Christmas sweater and excuse
to wear ya filthy animal and i also have
for you to great pics to watch in the
theater and to to watch at home of your
christmas break so let's get into it
with a pic at the theater one that
you'll definitely need to take tissues
too it's called a monster calls it's
based on a book and it's directed by jay
a by owner who's about to do jurassic
world to he also did the impossible and
the orphanage and like those two movies
this is also about growing up but it's
also about grief and it's about the
stories that we tell ourselves to get
through it all i have come to get you
home early the story centers on a young
boy who's trying to cope with so many
things his mother's illness relating to
his tough grandmother and the fact that
his father lives so far away and those
three are played by felicity jones
Sigourney Weaver and Toby Kebbell and
then right when Connor is at his lowest
point a giant tree monster arrives with
Liam Neeson's voice to tell him three
stories three stories that are going to
show him how to cope with all of it
what's your latest Roy text break the
windows brick
it's okay that you're angry I'm angry
too and if you need to break by God
now the stories are rendered so
beautiful on the big screen with
watercolor like animation that
completely sucks you in and it's very
emotional I thought that I dealt with
grief in a very touching way and not
emotionally manipulative at all that was
my opinion but I have to say when i saw
it at the toronto film festival everyone
around me was sobbing I just heard so
much sniffling and even me who never
really cries in movies found myself a
big sobbing mess at the end of this one
you can see a monster calls in select
theaters this weekend it's gonna be
expanding very soon i wish i had a
hundred years 100 years i gift you
I'm afraid of course you are afraid but
you will make a ship
for this is why you called me come on
the next film out in theaters this
weekend is one you've probably heard a
lot about recently because had a big
awards watch on it but then it didn't
get any nominations for Golden Globes or
sags I'm talking about silence by Martin
Scorsese could still be an Oscar
contender we have to wait and see but
that was a bit of a surprise snub
because this is Scorsese's dream project
this is his passion project the film
that he's been trying to make for 28
years it's all about faith and religion
and follows Jesuit priests in 17th
century Japan Ferrera is lost to us he
denounced God in public and surrendered
the faith that's not possible for the
Ferrara risked his life to spread our
faith all over Japan it seems to me that
our mission here is more urgent than
ever we must go find father Ferreira it
must be Liam Neeson week because silent
stars Liam Neeson along with Andrew
Garfield Adam driver and brilliant
Japanese actor Ishay ogata this is a
long sometimes really tough to get
through movie but beautifully made there
is no denying you know whether you can
relate to the religious aspect or not
whether you can relate to the plight of
this these priests or not the struggle
that they go through what you can't deny
is how beautiful this film looks it is
full of mist and shadows and beautiful
locations and look so great on the big
screen of course it's mainly about the
questions that are talked about in the
film it's all about having doubt having
faith and it's these kind of questions
that you can see Scorsese himself has
been mulling over the prayers for your
glory is there suffering
silence is definitely not scorsese's
best film by any means it's also not his
most entertaining but there's no doubt
that it's a very well made movie by one
of the greatest directors we have
working today so you can see silence in
limited theaters this weekend and then
should be expanding very soon precast
just bring through silence and now to
the two films available on video on
demand this week the first one I've
actually spoken about before on this
show and it's one of my favorite films
of the year american honey this is
andreia Arnold's road movie her
coming-of-age slice-of-life lyrical
drama which follows a young Dale played
by the wonderful Sasha Lane who joins a
group of misfits who travel around
middle America selling magazine
subscriptions but it's all a scam it's a
business opportunity you go door-to-door
with some magazines we explore like
America we party come with us for me
personally american honey is an
enthralling road movie that shows you a
subculture that you don't often see on
screens it's full of music and full of
colors and shot in 43 aspect ratio which
makes it seem like you're really peeking
into a window into these people's lives
and you can see american honey on video
on demand check it out truck scared bank
and last but not least there's a really
interesting documentary which definitely
blurs the lines between fact and fiction
it's called Kate plays Christine and it
follows the plate of an actress as she
prepares to play the role of Christine
Chubbuck the news reporter who killed
herself live on air you're going to play
this role you need to have like a
simmering undercurrent of some kind of
resentment or personal turmoil the fact
that she asked for her show to be
videotaped that date indicates to me
premeditation she's plotting something
but here's the twist there is actually
no movie that she's preparing for there
is no movie that exists in real life
instead this documentary is kind of
looking at the fascination we have in
turning these morbid true stories like
Christine's into a piece of
entertainment and also the kind of
transformation process that actors have
to go through when they're playing
real-life people it's a process that we
don't usually get to see we just hear
about I'm trying to get as close to it
as I can it seems to be somewhat
compulsive and we also don't get to see
the emotional toll that playing a dark
and disturbing role can have on an actor
this is a fascinating documentary it's a
riveting experiment I encourage you to
check out Kate plays Christine on
video-on-demand this weekend you die two
times the guy would you pass away and
then you died the last time somebody
mentioned your name
it's recap time it's recap time in
cinemas this weekend you can see the
emotional a monster calls the religious
silence at home you can watch I don't
know what this song is but it's okay the
lyrical american honey all the
experimental cake place Christine yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay enough with that
madness because it is the end of
Fandango indie movie guide I'm election
Malone you can chat to me anytime on
Twitter and leash Malone you can also
leave a comment below because I read all
of them let me know what you've seen
lately what indie film you've seen
lately that you have loved don't want to
hear about it and happy holidays I'm not
going anywhere these holidays so I will
see you again next week but